[ __ ] good Jeff that beige moon
Breakers really lighting up my board oh
do you got I mean my vagina god that
woman is a cancer bye Jeff oh god here
comes that weird little stay-at-home mom
oh my god what are you wearing hey
Maddie was up all night barfing on my
hair but it's great I'm very happy gross
I think she's just got her sadness all
over me here comes Amy just don't know
how you leave your kids all day and go
to work oh yeah
but I also need things like money right
I'll see you guys later just love Alcorn
she would such a hard worker I just said
that Vicki got four minutes to get
bossman to the vet which should be fine
you're super late peer marketing meeting
I can't believe I'm gonna be late to my
first soccer practice you having a bad
day it could not get any worse I called
this emergency PTA meeting to address an
issue that affects the safety of our
children terrorism the bake sale is this
a joke what's not now I can't do this
anymore
I'm done in this day and age it's
impossible to be a good mom screw it be
bad mom I'm in just somebody moved my
stool
Amy hi I was calling to see if you'd
like to join me at the movies this
afternoon
we allowed to do that this literally
been the best day of my life uga me to
get to it when we see you there
No bye I run the PTA nobody takes class
who plays the clarinet unless I say so
she's a bully you have to take down
these perfect moms I say we go punch
that chick right in the tits yes this is
the best PTA meeting ever
I haven't have sex with my divorce well
if I get someone who's not circumcised
run out of room screaming it's like
finding a gun in the street just scream
and get out of there
oh I love my baby so much you help sorry
not a great swimmer I think it's one
beautiful a Dory yes story yes